hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and I see we have a number of questions
here
that uh
saved up let's see let's pick one here
Paul asks are we close to making face
recognition a ubiquitous replacement for
passwords and electronic systems which
require login
negating the need to remember and
constantly change passwords
well
so
the okay few different things what one
question is sort of how does face
recognition work
and uh another question would be sort of
how good is it another question would be
sort of what's uh what other methods are
there of sort of identifying yourself
for the sake of your computer and so on
so in terms of face recognition the
um there's sort of a question of how
what what is there that is the same
about a face you know you have your
ordinary face you have the your face
making is some weird expression you have
your face wearing sunglasses you have
your face wearing a hat you have your
face when you uh you know cut yourself
somewhere
Etc et cetera et cetera
um you have a lot of different small
variations of your face and the question
is can your computer still tell it's you
or actually the big thing recent times
the masked face so to speak uh now most
face recognition methods failed on
masked faces so to speak uh and I think
they failed also for humans often on
masked faces we couldn't tell who
somebody was in that case unless we were
picking from a fairly small set of
possibilities
but
so the question is what can you tell
about a face that is independent of sort
of the the detailed conditions of the
face and maybe also if you don't look at
your computer or your phone for five
years and you're five years older
particularly if you're young uh you know
that means your face will look quite
different and can one tell it's the same
person so to speak or you know if you're
if you're set up that way you know you
grow a beard you you do this all kinds
of different things you could do
so
what's tended to happen is uh one common
technique is to try and use kind of the
three-dimensional structure of the face
and the way that typically works is your
phone or something uh tries to sort of
visualize your face in 3D and a common
way to do that is using this approach
called structured light where
essentially you project a grid of
infrared light that we can't see with
our eyes but which the computer's camera
or the phones camera can see you project
this grid onto your face what's the
point of doing that well if you have
something which would ordinarily be a
grid if on a flat surface it's uh it's
IT projects as a grid when the surface
isn't flat that grid will be deformed or
and the deformation will show you kind
of the the shape of the of the surface
and so that's a technique for figuring
out kind of what is the
three-dimensional shape of the thing
that you're projecting the grid onto
which in this particular case might be a
face so that's a way to get a slightly
more robust sense of kind of what what
is that face that's in front of my phone
so to speak well it has this
three-dimensional shape and that's um
so so that's a that's a kind of a an
approach
now the next question is well you know
between the person who just put on
sunglasses and the person who uh you
know decorated their face in this way or
that way
how much change can you make to one
person's face and how far away does that
leave you from another person's face or
are you going to get confused about
whose face you're actually looking at
um this is uh I I don't know all the
details about sort of how far you can go
and so on I think what is often the case
is that for things like passwords you
are really just trying to say uh is it
plausible that this person is the person
who they say they are so to speak you
know the username and you're trying to
verify is this in fact plausibly the
person whose username is that and even
if it could be the case that out of a
thousand people one of them would turn
out to be one who would successfully
trigger that face recognition that's
still okay because you know 999 times
out of a thousand at least
the the thing will correctly verify that
yes it is the person who it said it was
and and if that number is a million or
something it gets good enough that it's
probably considered okay it's a
different problem from the problem of uh
the the thing that I think is is
slightly problematic in the world of you
know you just have some random camera on
a street somewhere and it says who's
that person who just walked by
um that's a different problem that's a
than the question of verifying the
person who just typed in their username
is it plausibly that person who is
actually using this phone the problem of
of being able to say okay out of a a
billion people who might walk along that
street which particular one is this
that's a more difficult problem than
verifying that this that oh we think
it's this person because that's the
username they typed in you know now
let's see if we can verify that
I think people uh different times have
told me different things about what
aspects of faces are the most important
for modern face recognition systems
sometimes people say it's things about
you know the ears and the height of the
ears and so on because that's something
doesn't change when you put on
sunglasses or whatever else
um I'm not sure what the what the
current uh thing that's used is although
I think the three-dimensional structure
is an important piece in modern times
um I think
this uh uh so in terms of of well what
are the different ways you can tell it's
you so to speak
there are a whole variety I mean you
know there's there's fingerprints
there's uh things to do with the the
iris of one's eye there's uh uh lots of
lots of detailed things and you know
even between uh oh and there's things
like uh uh if you're prepared to talk to
something there's details of the of your
voice most of these things can be
changed by sort of stuff that happens
every day to people some less than
others I mean you know if it's a if it's
the iris of your eye you might put a
contact lens on that has some different
pattern on it if it's your fingerprint
you might have uh you know smooshed your
finger somehow and that will change your
fingerprint there are all sorts of
different things that that um can change
kind of the the uh these aspects of the
sort of the the the you that the
computer recognizes so to speak I mean
ultimately probably uh your your DNA is
a pretty good indicator of the who you
are
um and it isn't yet the case it's still
the case that to sequence a piece of DNA
or even to get what's called a DNA
fingerprint to pick out certain features
of a piece of DNA that might be
characteristic of a person or a species
or whatever else all of those things are
not kind of the kind of thing that could
conveniently happen when you like put
your finger on your phone or something
like this
um but yeah I think I think that that's
um
um
no I mean this question about uh
passwords and um uh sort of writing down
passwords and so on I mean it it used to
be the case that people would say oh you
should change your password for
everything once a month
um the problem with that is unless you
have some system for writing that for
for recording those passwords which
itself has certain vulnerabilities
people have the terrible habit of saying
oh I have to write it and change my
password every month let me write my
password on a piece of paper
um to so that I'll remember it otherwise
you know you changed every month and you
keep on not remembering what it is or
you come up with a scheme where you say
well if it's October I'll put a 10 in my
password and by the time you've got
schemes like that it's much easier to to
guess what's going on
so a few thoughts on that
uh
let's see
um
well the questions here about quantum
mechanics maybe I could tackle
one of those that's hard work guys
um
all right let's see if we can do some of
these
um
I was asking about correlations as Aaron
asking about some correlations among
qubits and how that differs from
ordinary bits and so on
all right well let's see
so
let's talk a bit about quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is this
Theory that's supposed to describe
ultimately small things in the world
like atoms and so on and electrons and
such like and sort of the big difference
from big things in the world is that
when it comes to big things in the world
we generally have the view that definite
things happen to big things in the world
like when you throw a ball it moves in a
definite trajectory moves in a definite
path but when it comes to small things
like electrons what quantum mechanics
says is that it isn't the case that
definite things happen instead there's a
whole set of possibilities for what can
happen and somehow what we perceive is
some uh sort of probability that of what
happened that's based on all of those
different possibilities for what could
have happened
now in our physics project this becomes
kind of more explicit and clearer what's
going on
in our physics project the
the way that everything gets represented
in the world is as this giant network of
kind of atoms of space
so we imagine that
space physical space is ultimately made
of things it's made of atoms of space in
the same kind of way that you know water
might be made of molecules of water and
all those atoms of space have this
feature that they are they have this
they're they're related to each other
and we can represent that by having this
kind of network of relations that
represents the structure of space and
not only the structure of space but also
the structure of kind of everything in
space
and then we imagine that time
is the process of sort of the continual
rewriting of this network that
represents space and everything in space
and so that's kind of the the nature of
time very different from the nature of
space in in the model that we have which
seems really to be a very uh convincing
model
um the the time is this kind of
computational process of continually
rewriting these relations these
connections between the atoms of space
okay so here's where things get tricky
when we say time consists of the
continual rewriting of these relations
between atoms of space it turns out
there isn't just a unique way to do that
at any given moment there are many
possible ways that you could rewrite
this set of relations between atoms of
space each one of those possible
rewritings essentially gives you a
different step in history it gives you a
different possible thing that could have
happened and when you put all those
together you end up with these many
different Paths of history that can
occur and so as I said sort of the core
idea of quantum mechanics is that there
are many possible Paths of History one
of the things that comes out in our
model that was not I think very clear
before is that these different parts of
History which in our model are just the
different possible sequences of
rewritings that can exist of of this
network that represents the structure of
space and everything in it those the
different possible rewritings can both
branch that is one state of the universe
can end up having two possible outcomes
but they can also merge in the sense
that two different states of the
universe can end up evolving to
something which is identical
now that I I should say one thing that
makes all of this
you know possible to talk about and
realistic to think about is that our
model space is ultimately discrete and
everything about what I'm saying is
ultimately consists of I can just count
I can say there's this number of atoms
of space there are this set of possible
paths I can enumerate those things you
know in the history of people's studies
of kind of matter and things in the
universe and so on people didn't know
200 years ago nobody had any idea that
uh things like water were made of
discrete molecules some people thought
that might be the case other people
violently disagreed and said no no it's
a continuous thing that is cannot be
broken down into discrete Atomic pieces
well
it nevertheless turned out that in terms
of making a theory of what was going on
like things like material heat that was
constructed in the end uh the correct
theory of heat was constructed on the
basis of the assumption that things like
water were made of discrete molecules
that could move around and then people
started constructing the idea of let's
look at enumerating all possible
configurations of this sort of glass of
water or something all the possible ways
places the atoms could be all the
possible configurations the items could
be in and people uh this is in the late
1800s people uh kind of very routinely
kind of assumed that things would be set
up in this kind of discrete way and then
when quantum mechanics was discovered
that was originally discovered in a
context of photons particles of light
that light was actually made of sort of
discrete lumps of stuff then it became
clear that there were atoms that matter
was made native discreet stuff it was
still the case that people imagined that
space for example and time were not
discreet in that way that's something
that's new in our model is that space
and time like atoms like photons like
other things are in fact discreet
well
as soon as you say that everything space
time and so on it's all discrete it
becomes a lot easier to kind of talk
about things like all these different
possible branches of history and so on
if you're trying to do that using
continuous mathematics using mathematics
that's based on calculus and so on it's
really very hard it's very hard to
Define what you're talking about because
it's kind of like you've got these many
paths but they're not distinct parts
that you can count there's some kind of
complicated mathematical structure
that's very hard to Define so so one has
a huge candy cap if one's saying let's
think about these things in terms of
traditional kind of calculus based
mathematics what's made possible our
physics project is kind of this idea of
discreetness which is an idea that's
very fundamental to computation we talk
about having discrete bits of data in
our computer and things like that these
are all like it's a one or it's a zero
it's not a 0.725 five uh value so to
speak it's it's a definite it's a yes or
it's a no so to speak so that idea of
discreetness is is important in in
setting things up okay so now
what uh
uh well now there's the question Okay so
we've got all these possible histories
for the universe
there's there's sort of a a big
experiential problem with that which is
that we in our normal existence imagine
that definite things happen in the
universe we don't perceive the universe
to be something where there are all
these different possible Paths of
History going on we perceive there to be
definite things happening in the
universe so the question is how does
that happen
well the the answer is
in in large part the answer is that
we are kind of averaging over large
chunks of sort of the space of histories
of the universe
when we're looking at something like I
don't know a gas or liquid or something
like that we put our finger in it in
water and we're running it along and
we're seeing what happens there are lots
of individual molecules trillions and
trillions and trillions of individual
molecules that are hitting our finger
and making the water move around with
certain and certain speeds and things
like this but we don't notice that we
just notice the aggregate effect of all
of those molecules that are hitting our
finger and making the water behave in
the way that the water behaves
well that's what happens in in the case
of sort of averaging over different
molecules in water we're also averaging
over different atoms of space whenever
we perceive space to be kind of
continuous we can just move from here to
there we don't go in jumps from here to
there that's because we're pretty big
very big compared to the atoms of space
so for us what would be kind of discrete
jumps really we perceive as continuous
kind of like we know that a computer
screen is made of pixels yet we can
watch a movie that seems to have kind of
uh continuous things happening in the
movie even though in the end we know
it's made from a bunch of discrete
pixels and so it's the same thing with
our perception of space and motion in
space and so on now it's a little bit
more abstract to talk about the fact
that we are sort of averaging over a
bunch of different histories in the
universe but the reason that we end up
sort of inevitably doing that is that
just as the universe versus branching
and merging and so on with all these
different possible threads of History so
too are our brains and so in a sense
what's happening is our brain which is
doing all this branching emerging and so
on that branching emerging is causing if
if we thought our brain was sort of at a
different definite place in what we call
branchial space the space of possible
branches of History if we thought our
brain was kind of at a definite place in
branchial space well really it's not
because progressively over time it's
kind of moving around in brown shell
space and what we perceive as being sort
of our uh our perception of the universe
our perception of our internal kind of
Consciousness so to speak is something
which is quite extended in bronchial
space there are many different possible
branches of history that we aggregate
together to make what we consider to be
our sort of threat of experience and so
that means that what
uh where where we we then can say oh
there are all these different threads
that do slightly different things in
detail but we're aggregating them all
together just like all those individual
molecules in the water we're doing
different things in detail but we
aggregate them all together and come up
with some definite conclusion and that's
kind of our our typical perception of
the universe
now if we look at exactly the right kind
of experiment we can start seeing the
fact that there isn't it isn't the case
that there really is just one branch of
History one one thread of History we can
start seeing the fact that there are
these separate threads of history and
it's just like when it comes to
perceiving I don't know the fact that
water is made of definite of discrete
molecules that became possible when
people had microscopes when people
realized you could like look at pollen
grains being pushed around with Brownian
motion or other kinds of effects like
that it's something where with the right
instrumentation we could kind of get a
sense that in fact for example water
wasn't a continuous kind of thing so
similarly with quantum mechanics around
1900 between different studies of kind
of light from atoms and uh and things
that involve essentially electronic
amplification we were able to get to the
point where we could actually sort of
see those individual threads of history
at least in some very special cases and
notice that things weren't there wasn't
just one kind of thread of experience
and this is kind of the the basis for
quantum mechanics is not the way it's
usually explained but that's the way
that we can Now understand it from our
physics project
um the uh what happened is the
mathematics of describing these
different essentially branches of
History these different Quantum states
that one can get that mathematics
developed in the 1920s mostly and
essentially what happened is that one
started to be able to say well we've got
a thing let's say it's an electron and
the electron can either be spinning this
way or that way and there are two
possibilities and quantum mechanics says
there's only two possibilities in this
setup and but we can end up with
something where we don't where our kind
of perception of the universe is such
that both those possible qualities are
there both those possibilities can
happen in some sense
now at some point if we kind of want to
get to the point where we have a
definite thread of experience we're
going to have to make a decision was it
was it actually the up direction or was
it the down direction we're going to
have to make a Quantum measurement that
decides that
and
it depends on
but at the level of individual electrons
individual electron spins and so on we
can maintain kind of this this kind of
we can maintain those both possibilities
for quite a while and we don't have to
our kind of common experience doesn't
sort of force us to make a decision
between these in in other cases where
some great big effect in the world you
know the uh uh well the the rather
gruesome one that that's commonly
discussed as you know a cat is it a live
or dead type thing
um and you don't sort of imagine that
there's that you imagine that you can
definitely tell it's alive or it's dead
and you don't have something which is a
superposition of states of the cat being
alive and dead but that's less obvious
for something like an individual
electron
Okay so the one of the questions is
can you make use of the fact that there
are all these different threads of
history that that there isn't just one
thing that happens that there are many
things that sort of internally happen in
quantum mechanics can you make use of
those multiple threads of History to for
example make a more efficient computer a
quantum computer can you for example
there are many uh problems that might be
faced by a classical computer I don't
know uh typical ones might be things
like oh you're trying to find a way to
go through a graph you're trying to find
a path the shortest path through a graph
okay you can try all these different
possible paths and you know can you and
then you might compare them and say
what's the shortest one or you could
take some
something like factoring a number where
you say if we could guess this set of
integers that are the factors of our
number when we multiply them together we
can easily check it's our number but to
determine from our number how to break
it down into those factors might be
really hard there are a whole bunch of
problems where one can for example well
we're sort of trying out multiple paths
is important in some problems it's even
the case that once you get a path that
is a winning path it's easy to check
that it's a winning path those are the
so-called NP non-deterministic
polynomial time problems typically
um of which uh
well factoring is an example of of an NP
problem it's not known whether it's
so-called NP complete but it's an NP
problem for sure
so anyway what one might think is with
this quantum computer you've got all
these different Paths of History surely
one can use one path of History to to
try each of the different possible
fractions of the number and that way we
can in parallel run all these different
computations and that's going to be a
better deal than just having to use an
ordinary computer where we have to run
one thing then the next thing then the
next thing obviously modern computers
have for example multiple cores where
one can do a certain amount of
parallelization just by virtue of
sending one instance to the computation
to one computer core another to another
computer core but kind of the idea for
quantum mechanics will be use the
intrinsic parallelism of the universe to
be able to to get all these computations
done in a faster way
okay well that's well and good
um the real problem with this is how do
you know what the answer is at the end
and how do you figure out in the end
you've got all these different threads
of history and they may all have
different things going on on them but we
as humans want to have a definite This
Is The Answer type result and so that
kind of knitting together of all these
different threads of History to come out
with the one definite answer that's not
a trivial process and that's a process
which has been pretty hard to describe
in kind of the traditional formalism of
quantum mechanics it's a little bit
easier to describe in our models of
physics and it's not obvious that the
effort to kind of knit together the
threads of history is any less great
than the effort to just follow all the
different threads to begin with in other
words do you actually get something
fundamentally different fundamentally
more efficient by saying oh we're going
to break this Quantum computation up
into all these different possible
abilities in sort of the insides of
quantum mechanics and then but then
there's a question of do we how do we
knit them together to get a definite
conclusion of the kind that we humans
want now if we humans were operating
ourselves right down at the quantum
scale if our brains had features where
we could in our brains hold separately
those different possibilities in the
superposition it will be a different
story but what we typically imagine when
we talk about Quantum Computing is
quantum Computing for the human user so
to speak not Quantum Computing for the
com for the quantum alien so to speak
who's operating purely in a Quantum way
and who can hold in their brain these
two different superpositions of what's
going on
okay so I think the question had to do
with with uh correlations between
different
um
uh bits and so on and I think the thing
to understand is that
in
okay what once when when the different
threads of history in the universe are
running and doing their thing these
threads of History are operating
independently or they might be merging
they might be branching that it's a it's
a thing going on in there that is has
sort of its own self-consistent
operation as soon as you say oh I'm
going to force those threads of History
to get knitted together so that I can
get a definite answer you've broken that
internal mechanism it's kind of like
like the uh the computer that is uh you
know you'll avoid the warranty if you
open this computer
um you uh as soon as you kind of go in
and humanize that all those sort of
individual threads of history that are
happening at the purely Quantum level
you've broken that Quantum mechanism
and so
the question of sort of what happens at
the level of the quantum mechanism is a
separate question from what happens and
what we perceive from that Quantum
mechanism
so for example
okay one of the issues is if you have
two uh bits two qubits which are these
kind of things that you would represent
so in a standard uh bit in a computer
when you store one bit of information in
a computer how is it actually stored at
different times there have been
different Technologies for doing it
these days it's actually stored by
having a certain amount of charge a
certain number of electrons maybe ten
thousand a hundred thousand electrons
per bit these days that are either
present in this kind of configuration of
transistors or not and that's what
determines is it a one or is it a zero
back in the day when I first used
computers there was a thing called core
memory where you would have a little
tiny piece of a little uh circular
magnet and uh the the one bit was
recorded and having the magnetization of
the circular magnet going one
orientation and the zero bit was the the
orientation of the magnet magnetization
being the opposite way and that's pretty
analogous those magnets were big things
you could you could see them with your
eyes I mean they were they were you know
they looked they were like they were
sort of somewhat you know took effort to
see but you could definitely see them
with your eyes
in a sense in a in a sort of quantum
computer you're imagining those magnets
have shrunk down to the point where
they're just single electrons each and
the question of whether the magnetic
field is one way or the other is the
question of whether the electron is
spinning in one orientation or on the
other orientation and so that's kind of
the idea of a qubit is something like
that microscopic magnetic core memory
just made from single electrons each
now
one of the questions then is what are
the
uh when you when you have these
different things happening and you have
different uh configurations of electron
spins for example that represent
different uh different things you're
storing
one of the issues will be if you've got
two electrons and they start off being
having some correlation like one of them
is up one of them's down and you know
that they're always paired together one
up as one and one down
and then you say well somehow we're
going to separate those two electrons in
space we're going to move them apart
well
normally when you move things apart
they're no longer particularly
correlated with they don't have any
reason to be correlated with each other
you know one electron can have one thing
happen to it the other electron can have
something different happen to It
Whatever correlation might have existed
originally between those two electron
spins will be destroyed one would think
by separating those two electrons apart
um and in in general if you wanted those
electrons to to cooperate again the way
they'd have to do that is by like
sending a signal from one electron to
the other and so how do you send a
signal where you might send a radio
signal you might send a light signal you
might send a neutrino signal whatever
kind of signal you send the maximum
speed at which that signal can go in
physical space is the speed of light so
if these electrons are far separated
that the the um the the the the the to
make sure that they're correlated will
take a time that is uh depends on how
far apart they are and the speed of
light
okay but
when you're dealing with quantum
mechanics you can end up saying well in
a particular thread of History we know
the electron has this configuration even
though we we know that we've got this up
down configuration even though the uh
that's that's what happens in one thread
of history and another thread of History
something different will happen
and we can set it up so that even though
the electrons are far separated in space
in that particular thread of History we
know that there wasn't this flipping
around one of the electrons because that
threat of history is a definite threat
of History a definite thing happens
another thread of history is something
different will happen but so what what
can what one can set up here is
something where if you could separate
out one thread of History one would know
that there was this correlation between
these two electrons even though the
electrons may be in space very far apart
but because it's a single pure thread of
History we know that the electrons have
this form and because nothing have kind
of because it's a single thread of
History nothing kind of kind of got in
there to change it because that will be
a different thread of History if it had
done that so that's why in quantum
mechanics it's called a pure state where
one's got something where well it's a
sort of single thread of history that
one's dealing with and that single
thread of History can make it look like
there's these correlations between
electrons in one place in a completely
different place
um and and that's kind of a weird effect
because if one could really hone in on a
single threat of History one would know
this correlation existed even though
those electrons might be very far apart
and so there are actual experiments that
have been done which show that yes you
can home in on essentially a single
thread of History uh at least in terms
of the electrons other things in the
universe might be have correspond to
different threads of history but at
least as far as the electrons are
concerned you can have this the single
threat of history and so that's how you
can get this kind of this surprising
correlation between these electrons
because that correlation exists because
you're dealing with a single thread of
history as soon as you knit together of
the threads of History to make an actual
measurement you you kind of lose this
effect of being able to have this sort
of separated uh separated thing go on so
that's uh that's that's kind of why you
can get correlations between qubits that
uh so long as you are maintaining the
sort of pure pure single thread of
History you can maintain those
correlations in a way that isn't is very
different from the way that you can make
things be correlated when you're dealing
with sort of we know what happened
definite uh kind of uh behavior that you
get when you perceive the universe as we
humans do where we're averaging across a
large number of threads of History This
is complicated stuff I'm I'm um uh the
the
you know the mathematical formalism that
describes how this works apart from the
measurement part which is a mess the
other stuff is is clean formalism that
we've known for 100 years
the although it is clearer what's going
on when you think about things in terms
of our physics project in terms of these
very discrete set of possibilities and
all that kind of thing but that's um
that's a little bit of an idea of how
that works
um
um let's see
okay so spare is saying perhaps a
conscious Observer is in fact the result
of the underlying physical system
building a model that averages out all
the parallel threads into a coherent
story yes there's a lot to that I mean I
think
one of the critical things about
consciousness
is this idea that we have a definite
thread of experience that is persistent
Through Time
and without that we we really have
something very different from our human
experience of of the world now as far as
the world itself is concerned there are
many different threads of History
there's uh not only are these threads of
history that are associated with quantum
mechanics there's also this whole uh
even greater collection of threads of
History associated with a rulial space
associated with the the set of all the
possible rules that can be used to
update the universe which we think is
sort of all operating at the same time
to make this whole kind of rouliad
construct of which we're sampling just a
tiny piece and so the fact that we have
a definite view about what's happening
in the universe is a consequence of the
fact that we are sort of aggregating
okay so so there are several different
effects we're taking a small slice of
all the possibilities just because we're
we're a certain size in the universe we
don't span the the whole universe we
don't know what's happening everywhere
in the universe we don't span all of
real space we don't span all the
branchial space we are localized in
those different kinds of space so we
only have a a kind of a parochial local
impression of what's going on
that's one thing the other thing is
that's what happens because we're small
compared to those kinds of the the whole
universe and those kinds of spaces but
we're also quite big compared to the
individual atoms of existence so to
speak or the atoms of space and so we're
averaging many of those and that's one
of the reasons that we can get a robust
notion of yes this is a definite
experience we had happen at the level of
all of this microscopic stuff that's
going on there's a lot of complicated
random looking stuff that's happening
but we get to aggregate lots of that
because we're pretty big and that's why
we imagine there's a single threat of
experience what's not obvious is that
that aggregation will be consistent it
could be the case that we could take
these through threads of history and we
say we're just going to assume the same
thing happens on these two threads and
it could turn out that that assumption
is just vastly wrong and that that we
get completely incompatible we can't
make up laws of physics because there
are all these weird things that keep on
happening and that are incompatible with
any consistent laws we make up the fact
that doesn't happen is a consequence in
our model of this phenomenon called
causal invariance which basically is a
thing that says even though there may be
two different branches of History those
branches were always in the end merge
and that's a necessary feature by the
time you have branches that correspond
to all possible Rules by which things
can be updated it's inevitably the case
that any branch will eventually be able
to merge it's less obvious that that
would be true when you specialize to a
particular set of rules when you do
something more like the pure quantum
mechanics and so on but it seems to be
true there we think it's true there too
so
uh that's that's kind of a um uh a
thought about that but I think that the
important thing about Consciousness is
it's big but it's small it's big in the
sense that it is able to average over
and sort of take this consistent slice
of all of these underlying sort of
random details of what's Happening
underneath it's big at that level but
it's small compared to the universe of
all possibilities
if it wasn't small compared to the
universe of all possibilities it would
be hard to have a coherent notion of us
in other words if we for example were
very extended and even in physical space
it's like what's our experience well you
know we can have an experience based on
where we are or we're seeing these
things we're seeing those things but if
we experience the whole universe all at
once it's much harder to say we have a
definite story about what happened to us
it's it's like all these different
things are happening it's even worse
when we look in rural space at all the
possible different uh description
Frameworks for the universe because
that's a place where we end up with sort
of this very incoherent view of all the
possible things that are happening we
don't have this coherent sense that this
is how the world works these are all
these possibilities for how the world
can work and we are kind of spanning all
of those and so in some sense if we're
if we're too big then we don't really
have a coherent sense of self we don't
really have a coherent sense of what we
are and how we kind of fit into the
universe
if we're too small
we're too subject to all of the sort of
random stuff that we can't really track
so we're kind of this intermediate size
in the universe that makes it possible
for us to have kind of the kind of
Consciousness experience that we
typically have if we were much bigger we
could no doubt have a a perfectly
meaningful experience of the universe
but it will be different it will be
something where you know if different
parts of our brains if it mattered what
the speed of light was
and uh you know communicating thoughts
between different parts of our brains
that would be we would have a very
different experience and very different
kind of way of thinking about things
than we do now and it's pretty hard to
imagine at least for me uh kind of that
level of difference in our kind of way
of perceiving the Universe I mean we're
we're kind of stuck in the way of
perceiving the universe that we've sort
of grown up with and that our senses
make obvious to use
um to try and imagine a different way of
perceiving the universe is is very
interesting but it's also very hard even
within you know the the uh your average
you know whale or dolphin or your
average whatever
um what you know what way of perceiving
the universe does one have there it's
hard to know
um but it's interesting to try to
imagine what other kinds of ways of
perceiving the universe might there be
and what kinds of very different physics
might you construct if you had different
ways
Steven Universe
let's see
William is asking about destructive
interference between threads of History
okay
um
all right
let's talk a little bit about that so
what is destructive interference
what how
happens is when you have uh waves
ripples on surface of water for example
they'll have a wave and it'll be going
and Rippling and it'll be going up and
down and so on well if you have two
sources of those waves you know you have
your somebody's like uh
The Bouncing something on the water in
one place and another place you'll get
these two kind of circular patterns of
ripples going out the leech correspond
to waves so what happens is if waves the
two waves from those two sources arrive
at a particular place and they're in
phase in the sense that that both waves
are up at the same time then they'll add
together
if they're both down at the same time
they'll look side together but if that
out of phase if one wave is up whenever
the other wave is down they will cancel
each other out it's like you you're
saying one sort of thing is telling the
water go up by a millimeter the other
one's saying go down by millimeter those
two things in the case of water just
sort of add together and the thing
destructively interferes you've got
waves from those two two collections of
waves and you might say well they'll
always add up and you'll get twice the
height but actually if they're out of
phase they can interfere and you'll get
zip zero height instead so one of the
things that was observed um ultimately
well in the was observed for light
um oh in the 1600s or so and it was
observed for atoms in the 1920s or 1930s
that it's possible to have destructive
interference between things that you
thought were kind of material objects
where you were wasn't just the water is
going up and down it was like there's a
photon there or there's an electron
there and it's it's like one plus one
equals zero so to speak so a typical
experiment you have these two slits and
you have something where you have a
source of light and the light can either
go through one slit or through the other
slit and what what happens is that you
don't actually get to see the sort of
the the the waves that correspond to the
um
uh
the sort of the the possibility of the
thing going through one slit or the
other but the end result is that you get
this interference pattern which you can
actually see on the uh you know the the
photons can land at this place on a
screen at the back behind the slits or
in that place but in between those
places there will be destructive
interference and no no photons will show
off that
how does that work in our kind of models
well
what you might think is if there are
different threads of History these
different threads of History must always
just add up that if there's one way that
the photons can go and there's another
way the photons can go then they must
just those must just be combined
well here's the problem the problem is
those different threads of history for
those to be experienced by us we have to
have netted together those threads of
History we have to have somehow taken
the it went through the left slash it
went through the right slit and combined
those and say Well it went through you
know the the combination of those as it
well it went through one of the slits
and we can sort of say it's there's a
certain rate of one certain rate of the
other we could combine those together
that's all well and good if we somehow
can successfully knit together that the
those different threads of history in
other words let's say we've got a
certain size in bronchial space we've
got a certain set of different threads
of history that we can say oh yes we're
aggregating across these threads of
History these are all things that are
consistent with being what we experience
just like when we're looking at I don't
know the finger and water we're
aggregating over all the molecules that
are spatially near us in in the water so
similarly in brown Shield space we're
aggregating over all parts of history
that are somehow near a particular place
maybe some particular path of history or
whatever that are near somewhere in
Branch Hill space okay so that's well
I'm good but now the question is what
happens if um uh if this
if the pause in bronchial space wind up
in very different places in branchial
space if the it went through the left
slit and it went through the right slit
if those two different threads of
History end up far far away in bronchial
space than we as observers can't knit
those together they're too far apart we
we are only of a certain size and we
can't uh we don't aggregate over that
region and so that's I think the
qualitative picture of what's happening
in destructive interference basically
what's happening is the different
possibilities the different threads of
History wind up being far away in
bronchial space and our effort to
aggregate threads of History isn't able
to span those two things isn't able to
bring them together so we just say uh
where'd the electron go where did the
photon go we don't know where it went
because neither of the threads of
History where it went through either
either of the these some slits is
something within sort of the domain that
we're aggregating to extract our threat
of experience I think that's the
qualitative picture of house at one plus
one can equal zero in a case like that
that by having these two different
things that wind up sort of a different
different corners of branchial space
they're far enough apart we never get to
aggregate them and so we can't say that
either of them ever happened at least
that's a qualitative picture we're
trying to fill in more of the
mathematics of how that works and it's
kind of tricky we sort of thought we had
an idea how to do that a couple years
ago but the mathematics of filling in
the mathematics is a is a complicated
story there and it really relates to
kind of the the correspondence between
the way things work in uh uh in
bronchial space the way things work in
physical space the kind of very weird
sort of way in which
um
the sort of space of possible branchings
can be kind of put in correspondence
with physical space it's kind of like if
you have a tree which has sort of an
infinitely branching collection of of
possibilities how do you take that tree
with its infinitely blanching
possibilities and arrange them in
ordinary in ordinary space in that
particular example when it's a pure tree
you can use hyperbolic space and so on
to to make various kinds of Arrangements
but the situation we have here is more
complicated than that and that's kind of
the type of thing that that's uh that's
involved
well there's a question here
uh
could our brains be a quantum computer
well
um
not if you believe in not in not in an
interesting way
in the following sense if you believe
that you have a single thread of
experience you're not using quantum
mechanics in a serious way because if
our brains were sort of truly in the
innards of being a quantum computer
they would be able to kind of uh
they wouldn't we would not have our
description of the world that says this
happens then this happens then this
happens definite things happen in the
world we would have a very different
sort of description framework for the
world now can we imagine that one day
there will be a device that operates
purely at that level that never sort of
externalizes to be relevant to the human
Observer and so on yeah sure you can
imagine such a device happens all the
time in kind of the innards of quantum
mechanics but the externalization of
that depends on well what experience do
we as humans have based on what's going
on and if we had brains that were
fundamentally down and sort of the
quantum domain then we would be able to
fundamentally understand these Quantum
processes but our brains were very
different from the way our brains
actually are today and in particular
this thing that has been crucial to our
experience of the world this is this
idea of single threat of experience
wouldn't be there anymore so you know
you imagine the future of all humans
that have truths of quantum brains and
you are communicating you're talking to
one of those future Quantum brain humans
it would be very confusing because to
that future human so to speak if you've
got you know classify them as a human
um they would be kind of imagining all
these different threads of history that
were going on and and you'd be sort of
saying but what actually happens what's
actually going on what actually happened
and they're like I don't know what
you're talking about you know it's it's
kind of like all things are happening
all these different threads of History
are all happening at the same time I
don't know what um and and you know it's
a it's a different level of experience I
mean it it's sort of um
I'm sure there's an analogy if you look
at uh modern
um uh sort of modern technology and you
view it from sometime in the past and
you say the modern technology has sort
of expanded our experience of the world
and you might say well how would you
describe that how would you feed that
back to a a uh you know a Consciousness
from 2000 years ago or something how
would you feed back the things that we
now are able to experience how would you
feed it to somebody who to a mind a
brain that doesn't have those uh that
doesn't have the ex the experience of
having those kinds of experiences so to
speak and I think that's a challenging
thing so I think in uh the you know
could we enable sort of the quantum bit
in our brains
um well if we do that if if that was
possible and I think the scales are
somewhat wrong for that to really be
possible if that was possible and I
think probably biology goes to some
trouble to make our brains actually
believe in a definite sort of thread of
experience because that's what's
necessary to operate in the ways that
biological organisms tend to operate in
the world
um and so you know there's there's quite
a bit of effort the brain goes to to
kind of aggregate our sensory
experiences to this one kind of layer of
this one kind of attention string that
is uh that is going through time so to
speak
um and that's uh
so so I think uh you know whatever the
hardware is doing it's still the case
that being human is a lot about sort of
aggregating that that things together
into that single thread of experience
and if we say well we don't really care
about being human well well and good
fine but you may not have something
which to us today in you know 21st
century humans uh could can actually
relate to so to speak
um
right there's a comment here I need to
go in a moment here but but um there's a
comment here about um
uh
neurons firing in the brain and and um
uh they're kind of um uh what kind of
computation is going on there I mean one
of the sort of I would say it's almost
the fundamental problem of Neuroscience
is to know what matters in the brain
that is to have a description of the
brain that is below the level of just
saying oh thinking is happening and we
can do psychology about it
and above the level of and this is how
an individual neuron works and this is
how the electrical signals go from here
to there and so on what is the
intermediate level of description that
is between so so for example for a
computer we have an intermediate level
of description it's the typical kind of
machine code and then the layers of
software that we build up above that
machine code but in talking about a
computer we're not down at the level of
saying where'd that individual electron
go which uh you know there's a level of
description that we sort of understand
is there that is above the level of the
individual transistors switching in the
computer and all those kinds of things
and so that's that's the um
uh that's that's kind of the um uh uh
but the question is what
in the case of the brain what is the
kind of uh low-level language of the
brain that is above individual neuron
firings and Below just this whole big
thought happened we don't know
and we get some better Clues maybe from
artificial neural Nets that seem to have
some characteristics in common with the
biological ones we have but even with
artificial neural Nets we're kind of a
bit of a loss when we build up some
complicated machine Learning System to
give a kind of science level narrative
description about what's happening in
there
so
yeah so anyway a few thoughts about that
I see a bunch of questions here which
are all very interesting but I think
that I have to go and do some day job
kinds of things
um and uh
I'm you guys are tempting me with a few
other questions here that I just um
um
uh
Aaron is asking what Wolfram language
functions will be most improved if they
could use 20 million logical qubits on a
quantum computer
uh
it's kind of an interesting question if
if there was even even just let's say we
had
I mean okay the computer that I used
when I first started using computer 50
years ago now
um had a cycle time of around two
microseconds
computers that I use today
uh
have
cycle times that are about uh five
thousand times faster than that
so what is different now that the
computer is 5 000 times faster than it
was back then what would be different
again if the computer I used was a
hundred thousand times faster than the
computers today a million times faster
than computers today and it's not
inconceivable that forget quantum
mechanics are such forget these parallel
threads which I think are are going to
be hard to really make use of in a
computer just reduce the size of the
components just be dealing with
individual electrons rather than a
hundred thousand electrons doing things
with individual molecules rather than
whole aggregations of molecules it's
possible to imagine much faster
computation forgetting about whether
you're doing this multi-threaded kind of
multi-quantum type type thing and you
can ask the question well what would be
enabled by having a computer that's a
thousand or a hundred thousand times
faster than the computers we have today
I think it's interesting because a lot
of that question revolves around
so in the end and it's a human user and
the human user has you know our eyes are
sensitive only every 30th of a second or
something to what the what the image
looks like if we started switching out
images a million times a second we
wouldn't notice we'd only notice what
comes up every 30th of a second or so
um it's similarly you know we know our
ears are only sensitive to maybe uh
um you know 40 000 if you're if you're
lucky uh kind of changes of sound
pressure per second
um things like this so there's there's a
question of well the stuff that the
computer is actually showing to us
um there will come a point not too far
from now when the our sensory inputs are
actually the bottleneck in terms of
getting stuff from our computer to our
brains
you know right now we can we can make
sounds we can't completely synthesize
sounds uh fast enough on computers we
have today to make you know the
synthesized sort of version of some
spoken voice that is uh transformed in
some way or some way we can't make
something which is a completely
realistic you know every pixel is Right
image that we could see through our some
display that's displayed to our eyes we
can't quite do that yet we will be able
to do those things those things are very
much on track to get done you know
exactly how many years it will be as
hard to predict but a modest number I
think that we will get to the point
where we can routinely synthesize much
of what is sort of our at least static
everyday kinds of phenomena in the world
and to go to make the computer faster at
doing that it's like irrelevant because
the bottleneck is us and our ability to
absorb that data now on the back end
there are all kinds of computations
where to work out that thing that you
can feed to the human that could take a
lot of effort
and it's an interesting question that I
have not thought that much about is what
could we really achieve if we had
computers that were a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand times faster
um what kinds of things that um I mean I
will tell you in the development of
language
I've always taken the point of view that
we should develop the language as we
think we should develop the language we
should have a clean elegant
specification of making some particular
kind of thing computable and then the
computer hardware and systems will
always catch up
so
you know for example
but there are things that that we can
have a clean and elegant specification
but it's kind of annoying for a human to
use there are things like let's say a
user interface but it's a clean elegant
specification but you know things move
around at the rate of one one little
movement per second way too slow for a
human to be happy with it but then
computers get faster and there's more
and more that you can kind of do in the
loop in in a clean elegant way within
the the time frame that for a human
constitutes kind of sort of a continuous
flow of time so that's one of the things
we've noticed in the building world and
language that there's more and more for
example user interface that we can just
specify in a nice clean elegant way and
it runs fast enough that for a human
user it seems to be something that is a
smooth kind of experience
and so there are things like that where
there are things where the sort of the
clean elegant specification it's like
can we go from a clean elegant
specification of something to how it
actually works can we do that in real
time are computers fast enough that we
can I don't know do something where we
have defined some some axiomatic
framework and uh
um we um
uh we then simply uh say the computer is
fast enough that in real time every time
we ask for something it's Computing all
these different paths and so on and
telling us the results I think those are
the kinds of things we can imagine that
that it's possible to go from the high
level specification to what we
experience it's possible to go from a
more a more a higher and higher level
specification to the things we
experience so for example we might be
able to describe something in some
visual scene where we just give it in
terms of something where we've we've
specified kind of the almost in in the
end the rules of the universe so to
speak and then we just sort of say to
the computer okay go go work out their
consequences and show me the results to
do that for the whole universe is
clearly not possible but to do that for
larger and larger chunks of the
universal as we have faster and faster
kind of pieces of programmable matter so
to speak represent our computers uh gets
to be something we can do
all right I think I have to wrap up for
today
um so I look forward to continuing
another time and uh addressing some of
the questions that I didn't get to today
and thanks for joining me I was a little
tired today so I might not have been as
coherent as sometimes
um but uh look forward to seeing you
another time
thanks for joining me and bye for now